Welcome to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, Denmark and the world, Episode One: the European Union.
Imagine Europe in the ruins after the Second World War.
The scale of international cooperation has grown ever since the end of that war, not least out of a strong wish to avoid new wars.
Future conflicts between countries were to be prevented.
Instead, countries should cooperate and find peaceful solutions.
Denmark takes part in this cooperation to a wide extent.
There has been, and still is, agreement among most of the parties in the Folketing that taking part mainly promotes Danish political and economic interests, and protects the country's security.
This has given Denmark influence on matters that reach beyond the country's borders.
But the decisions of these international organisations also help set the framework for Danish society.
International, and especially European, cooperation therefore has great importance for Denmark.
At the European level, it is especially the EU, the European Union.
Cooperation in the EU is particularly extensive and plays a big role for Denmark.
In addition, Denmark is, among other things, a member of the UN, NATO and the Council of Europe.
Denmark also cooperates with the other Nordic countries: Sweden, Norway, Finland and Iceland.
This takes place especially in the Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd, and the Nordic Council of Ministers, Nordisk Ministerråd.
The exams also ask this: the Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd, is the organisation for cooperation between the parliaments of the Nordic countries, and the Nordic Council of Ministers is the cooperation between the governments.
It is not called Nordtinget or the Nordic Union.
Now, the story of the European Union.
The first steps in its history were the European Coal and Steel Community, which was established in 1952 by six European countries.
Besides the wish to support peace and cooperation between the countries, one purpose was also to rebuild Europe economically and socially after the destruction of the war.
At the same time, the political world map had changed.
Europe was no longer the world's centre of power, and so the individual countries were to be strengthened by cooperating more.
A few years later, the six countries decided to go one step further.
In 1958, the Coal and Steel Community was expanded with the European Economic Community and the European Atomic Energy Community.
These three communities later became the European Communities, the EF.
The cooperation now became a broader economic cooperation.
Its purpose was especially to remove obstacles to trade between the countries, and thereby establish a more common market.
In 1993, the EU's internal market came into force.
This means that goods, services, persons and capital can move even more freely between the member countries than before.
The same year, the EF changed its name to the EU, the European Union.
The name change reflected that the cooperation, which until then had been cooperation on economic questions such as trade, agriculture and fisheries, was expanded with a broader range of political areas of cooperation.
Today, the EU consists of 27 member countries with a total of about 450 million inhabitants.
Here are the countries by the year they joined.
In 1958, the founding members: France, Germany, Italy, Belgium, the Netherlands and Luxembourg.
In 1973: Denmark and Ireland.
In 1981: Greece.
In 1986: Spain and Portugal.
In 1995: Austria, Finland and Sweden.
In 2004: Cyprus, the Czech Republic, Estonia, Latvia, Lithuania, Hungary, Malta, Poland, Slovakia and Slovenia.
In 2007: Bulgaria and Romania.
And in 2013: Croatia.
In addition, the United Kingdom joined the EU together with Denmark and Ireland in 1973, but left the cooperation again in 2020.
What is the EU for?
The EU's purpose is to solve common European problems.
The union is to strengthen cooperation in areas that are best handled by the EU's member countries together.
The EU's general objectives are to promote economic and social development, to strengthen Europe's role in the world, to strengthen the protection of European citizens' rights and interests, and to secure freedom, security and justice.
The EU countries cooperate today in almost all areas of society.
For example, an economic and monetary union has been established, the ØMU.
Under it, 20 member countries have a common currency, the euro.
EU cooperation also includes a common foreign and security policy.
In addition, there is police cooperation, cooperation on asylum and refugee policy, and the so-called Schengen cooperation, whose purpose is to create a common area without internal borders, but with a common external border.
The Schengen cooperation means that, as a starting point, the countries have removed personal checks at the borders within the Schengen area and made common visa rules for citizens from a number of countries outside the EU.
In the EU, the countries also cooperate on environmental protection, social conditions, employment, the labour market, education, regional development and foreign policy matters.
But there is a big difference in how extensive the cooperation is in the individual areas.
In some areas, common European legislation is drawn up.
In other areas, the EU is content to support the member countries' national policies.
In the EU cooperation, the member countries have given the EU some of the power that used to lie with the national parliaments and authorities.
Cooperation in the EU means that in some areas of law, EU legislation can be adopted that applies directly to citizens in the individual member country.
EU rules thus have the same effect as the country's own legislation.
Today many decisions in the EU are also made by so-called majority decisions.
That means a proposal can be adopted without all member countries agreeing.
A country can in other words be outvoted, but still be bound by the decision.
The EU is organised through a number of institutions that function independently of the member countries.
These are especially the European Commission, the European Parliament and the EU Court of Justice.
One example of an adopted EU law is the data protection regulation, most often called GDPR, the General Data Protection Regulation.
This law came into force in 2018 and sets requirements for how personal data is handled in the EU countries.
It has been of great importance for Danish companies and organisations, since there are new requirements for how and for how long they may store data about members and customers, as well as a requirement of consent when entering information about private persons.
A number of both public and private companies employ staff to make sure the companies' GDPR procedures are followed.
EU cooperation can also include matters that do not lead to actual EU legislation.
Instead, the aim is that the EU countries should learn from each other.
This can happen by the countries jointly formulating objectives for specific policy areas and then reporting on what they have done.
This is also called the open method of coordination.
The recommendations concern especially labour market policy, economic policy and social policy.
The member states have no duty to carry out the recommendations, but they often influence the member states' policy.
Here is your recap for Episode One.
The EU began with the Coal and Steel Community in 1952, with six countries.
In 1958 came the European Economic Community and the Atomic Energy Community, later the EF.
The internal market came into force in 1993, the same year the EF became the EU.
The EU has 27 member countries and about 450 million inhabitants.
The founding members in 1958 were France, Germany, Italy, Belgium, the Netherlands and Luxembourg.
Denmark and Ireland joined in 1973, together with the United Kingdom, which left in 2020.
20 members have the euro.
Schengen means no internal border controls.
GDPR came into force in 2018.
The institutions are the Commission, the Parliament and the Court of Justice.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which of the following international organisations did Denmark become a member of in 1973?
Option A: The EF, the European Communities.
Option B: The WTO.
Option C: The OECD.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende internationale organisationer blev Danmark medlem af i 1973?  A: EF  |  B: WTO  |  C: OECD
The answer is A: The EF, the European Communities.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: EF
Question 2.
What is the Nordic organisation that handles cooperation between the Nordic countries' parliaments called?
Option A: The Nordic Union.
Option B: The Nordtinget.
Option C: The Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd.
[DA] Hvad hedder den nordiske organisation, der varetager samarbejdet mellem de nordiske landes parlamenter?  A: Den Nordiske Union  |  B: Nordtinget  |  C: Nordisk Råd
The answer is C: The Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd.
It appeared in the November 2022, May 2025 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Nordisk Råd
That's the end of this part.
Well done.